dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir artificial
neural networks are very useful tools
that are able to learn and recognize
objects on images or learn the style of
Van Gogh and paint new pictures in his
style today we are going to talk about
recurrent neural networks so what does
the recurrent part mean with an
artificial neural network we usually
have a one-to-one relation between the
input and the output this means that one
image comes in and one classification
result comes out whether the image
depicts a human face or a train with
recurrent neural networks we can have a
one-to-many relationship it
the input would still be an image but
the output would not be a word but a
sequence of words a sentence that
describes what we see on the image for a
many-to-one relation a good example is
sentiment analysis this means that a
sequence of inputs for instance a
sentence is classified as either
negative or positive this is very useful
for processing movie reviews where we'd
like to know whether the user light or
heated the movie without reading pages
and pages of discussion and finally a
recurrent neural networks can also deal
with many to many relations translating
an input sequence into an output
sequence examples of this can be machine
translations that take an input sentence
and translate it to an output sentence
in a different language for another
example of a many-to-many relation
let's see what the algorithm learned
after reading Tolstoy war and peace
novel by asking it to write exactly in
that style it should be noted that
generating a new novel happens letter by
letter so the algorithm is not allowed
to memorize words let's look at the
results at different stages of the
training process the initial results are
well gibberish but the algorithm seems
to recognize immediately that words are
basically a big bunch of letters that
are separated by spaces if we wait a bit
more we see that it starts to get a very
rudimentary understanding of structures
for instance a quotation mark that you
have opened must be closed and a
sentence can be closed by a period and
it is followed by an uppercase letter
later it starts to learn shorter and
more common words such as fall death the
for me if we wait for longer we see that
it already gets a grasp of longer words
and smaller parts of sentences actually
start to make sense
here's a piece of Shakespeare that was
written by the algorithm after reading
all of his works you see names that make
sense and you really have to check the
text thoroughly to conclude that it's
indeed not the real deal it can also try
to write math papers I had to look for
quite a bit until I realized that
something is fishy here it is not
unreasonable to think that it can very
easily deceive a non-expert reader can
you believe this this is insanity
it is also capable of learning the
source code of the Linux operating
system and generate new code that looks
quite sensible it can also try to
continue the song let it go from the
famous Disney movie frozen
so recurrent neural networks are amazing
tools that open up completely new
horizons for solving problems where
either the inputs or the outputs are not
one thing but a sequence of things and
now signing off with a piece of
recurrent neural network wisdom well
your wit is in the care of side and debt
bear this in mind wherever you go
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
you